[Music]
I'm meeting my friend to go to library
now this is so weird to me though
because I usually wake up around this
time but I just stay at home and study
I've never been to library this early or
met another human being this early
because usually not many people are away
so this is gonna be fun
good morning
yeah I was actually kind of worried that
you wouldn't make it because you're not
necessarily a morning person I just
wanted to try your schedule to be honest
I want to see how a productive medical
students study and go about that day
okay yeah it should be interesting let's
get productivity together
well here we go that doesn't need a car
realize that I forgot my unique cards no
I don't think at 5am without a Unicode
we can get in uni but then shall we just
try a like rather than going back if are
people in they could let us in hopefully
[Music]
good morning
it is 9 15 now
if you're not a morning person if you
can like study better in the evening I
don't think there was any reason for you
to wake up early it's not your thing no
no that's okay I just I just didn't have
that much sleep last night I don't sleep
at 7 00 PM like you
I sleep 8 7 38 sometimes yeah that's not
normal people hours so that might not be
average but it is normal the world is
still running at 8pm okay well I'm not
miserable like you are right now
[Music]
so far I've been doing practice
questions because I have my final
medical knowledge exam of the year in a
week so to not hate myself for how
little I studied when the exam stress
comes upon I've made a realistic plan to
be able to cover all the topics before
the exam if I have enough time I choose
to dedicate each day to a specific
subject especially if it's one that I
struggle with or one that comes up a lot
in the exams then I prioritize those for
example I'm focusing on Pediatrics which
is child health for the whole day today
because it's a huge specialty and we get
lots of questions on it in the exam and
how is your sitting going in and what
are you studying I'm doing Masters in
clinical biochemistry my exam is in
oh obviously I would look at it as well
if someone was holding a camera and I
can only in five days I hope everything
will be fine yeah it'll be fine
hopefully
[Music]
we're leaving to get some breakfast
brunch
it's super sunny right now it's like 24
degrees which is really hot for the UK
and I forgot to put sunscreen on because
when we left in the morning it was still
not light outside but I've got some in
the bag so I'm gonna put it on now
I can't believe I'm doing this right now
like outside I should have done it when
we were still in the library
it's in my nose yeah I can see everyone
tissue it's gone too much of a hassle
[Music]
before we continue with the rest of the
video I want to thank skillshare for
sponsoring I started my YouTube channel
a year ago with the help of classes I
took on skillshare the only class I
learned editing from before I posted my
first video ever on YouTube was Ali
Abdel video editing with Final Cut Pro
skillshare class summertime is here and
I think it's a great time to learn and
explore your creative and career options
skillshare has classes on how to start a
business and refine your branding or if
you want to have more time for yourself
there are classes on time management and
productivity each class is extinct and
to the point and have these time stamps
where you can skip to the parts you want
to learn from first 1000 people to use
the link in my description will get one
month free trial of skillshare I'm going
to do some Pediatrics questions online
key under the sun
oh yeah
my butt is getting a little wet mine's
already wet and I can't accept it
[Music]
both COPD and Asthma are obstructive we
know asthma is like not getting the air
out so yen is reading his book oh yeah
you show it to be like I'm reading this
book I'm reading this book I'm thinking
that's inside I'm reading this book it's
called Thinking Fast and Slow talking
fast
you talked fast no that's what I meant
it was a joke I've been studying
Outdoors on this beautiful day rather
than being stuck inside which has been
so nice but I feel like this can be
tricky especially if it's a public space
there are lots of distractions and it
can get uncomfortable but there are
study techniques that work quite well
Outdoors for example active recalling by
doing quick flash cards or listening to
voice notes to anything that doesn't
require lots of equipment or a
controlled space like I would struggled
to write down an essay Outdoors
[Music]
the thing is we got the takeaway price
because it was cheaper but now we're
gonna eat outside
[Music]
of this and that together yeah
why would you feed me
[Music]
it's because you're so lucky yeah I hope
all these luck goes to my son Let's
study so we don't need luck
[Music]
luck
it's time to sleep because I woke up
early I just being away for too long so
I want to sleep now that's exactly how I
feel I wake up early naturally and then
I just need to go to sleep early well
thanks for joining me again and trying
out my sleep schedule yeah it was pretty
fun it was pretty fun to roast me for my
sleep schedule probably no it works for
you so that's good I'm proud of you for
like even waking up to be honestly wake
up before